it is a big day for the clark county
school district later tonight the board
will vote on a plan
to possibly allow students back on
campus many parents and teachers though
have mixed opinions on this proposal
bianca holman is live from the school
board office
with more on this hi bianca hey good
morning alex
the school board actually posted a 205
page document and that's the
transitional plan and it's a hybrid
model to get kids back into the
classroom and
as you can expect of course parents and
teachers there's a
range of opinions regarding that
transitional plan now here's a little
bit more about what was included
the proposed plan includes two days of
face-to-face learning and three days of
distance learning for students each week
some students will be back in the
classroom as soon as january 4th
however parents will have the option to
remain in full-time distance learning if
they choose
strict cleaning protocols and
transportation requirements are included
in the plan as well
the school district posted a
questionnaire for cohort cohort
selections
this is information they would use to
implement the plan
we spoke with rebecca garcia the nevada
pta president
she says many parents are relieved to
finally have a plan in part for in the
in-person instruction
but there's still major concerns
one of the things that i hope i see the
trustees focus
on very specifically is the quality of
distance learning
because even in the hybrid model
students are still going to be spending
three out of five days a week in
distance education
and we know that at least a decent
percentage
maybe even up to half or more will
continue full-time
in distance education
and so if you're a parent and you have
not viewed the plan or completed the
survey you can do so by visiting the
district website
click on the plan transitional picture
it's right on that main landing page
when you go to it
and so again the board of trustees
they're meeting later on today at 5 pm
to discuss that hybrid transitional
model
again looking to implement that come at
the top of the january the top of the
year
reporting live from ccsd headquarters
bianca holman
8 news now